so we have a trapezoid here on the
coordinate plane and what we want to do
is find the area of this trapezoid just
given this diagram and like always pause
this video and see if you could figure
it out well we know how to figure out
the area of a trapezoid we have videos
where we derive this formula but the
area of a trapezoid just put simply is
equal to the average of the length of
the basis we could say base one plus
base two times the height and so what
what our base is here what are and what
is going to be our height over here well
we could call base one we could call
that segment CL so it would be the
length of segment CL right over here
I'll do that in magenta that is going to
be base one base to base 2 that couldn't
let me do that in a different color base
two would be the length of segment Oh W
or B two would be the length of segment
Oh W right over there and then our
height our height H well that would just
be an altitude and they they did want an
a dotted line here notice that
intersects bit enough for the base one I
guess you could say segment CL at a
right angle here and so this would be
this would be the height so if we know
the lengths of each of these if we know
each of these values which are the
lengths of these segments then we can
evaluate the area of this actual
trapezoid and once again if this is
completely unfamiliar to you or if
you're curious we have multiple videos
talking about the proofs or how we came
up with this formula you can even break
out a trap break down a trapezoid into
two triangles in a rectangle which is
one way to think about it but anyway
let's see how we could figure this out
so the first one is what is b1 going to
be b1 is the length of segment CL and
you could say well look we we know what
these the coordinates of these points
are you could say let's use the distance
formula and you could say well the
distance formula is just an application
of the Pythagorean theorem so this is
just going to be our the square root of
our change in x squared so our change in
X is going to be this right over here
and notice we're going from x equals
negative 4 to x equals 8 as we go from C
to L
so our change in X is equal to 8 minus
negative 4 which is equal to 12 and our
change in Y our change in Y we're going
from y equals negative 1 to y equals 5
so we could say our change in Y is equal
to 5 minus negative 1 which of course is
equal to 6 and you see that here 1 2 3 4
5 6 and the segment that we care about
it's length that we care about that's
just the that's just the hypotenuse of
this right triangle that has one side 12
and one side 6 so the length of that
hypotenuse from the Pythagorean theorem
and as I mentioned the distance formula
is just an application of the
Pythagorean theorem this is going to be
our change in x squared 12 squared plus
our change in Y squared so plus 6
squared and this is going to be equal to
144 plus 36 so the square root of of 144
plus 36 is one hundred 180 which is
equal to let's see 180 is 36 times five
so that is 6 square roots 6 square roots
of 5 all right let me not skip some
steps so this is the square root of 36
times 5 which is equal to square root of
36 is 6 so 6 square roots of 5 now let's
figure out B 2 so B 2 once again change
in x squared plus the square root of
change in x squared plus change in Y
squared well let's see if we're going
from we could set up a right triangle if
you like like this to figure those
things out so our change in X we're
going from X is at negative 2 X is going
from negative 2 to positive 4 so our
change in X is 6 our change in Y we are
going from we are going from y equals y
equals 5 to y equals 8 so our change in
Y is equal to 3 so just applying the
Pythagorean theorem to find the length
of the
here it's going to be the square root of
change in x squared six squared plus
change in Y squared plus three squared
which is going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to 30 36 plus 36
plus 9 which is 45 so square root of 45
which is equal to the square root of 9
times 5 which is equal to 3 square roots
of 5 and so we only have one left to
figure out we have to figure out H we
have to figure out the length of H so H
is going to be equal to and so what is
our if we're going from WN our change in
X is 2 change in X is equal to 2 we're
going from x equals 4 to x equals 6 if
you want to do that purely numerical
you'll say Oh care endpoint are X values
6 our starting point on X values for 6
minus 4 is 2 you see that visually here
so it's going to be the square root of 2
squared plus R let me write that radical
a little bit better so it's the square
root of our change in x squared plus our
change in Y squared our change in Y is
negative 4 change in Y is negative 4 but
we're going to square it so it's going
to become a positive 16 so this is going
to be equal to the square root of 4 plus
16 square root of 20 which is equal to
the square root of 4 times 5 which is
equal to 2 times the square root of 5
it's nice that the square root of 5
keeps popping up and so now we just
substitute into our original expression
and so our area of our trapezoid is
going to be 1/2 times 6 square roots of
5 6 square roots of 5 plus 3 square
roots of 5 plus 3 square roots of 5
let me close that parentheses times 2
square roots of 5 times 2 square roots
of 5 and let's see how we can simplify
this so 6 square root of 5 plus 3 square
roots of 5 that is 9 square roots of 5
let's see the 1/2 times the 2 those
cancel out to just be 1 and so we're
left with 9 square roots of 5 times the
square root of 5 well square root of 5
times square
five is just going to be five so this is
equal to nine times five which is equal
to forty five square units or units
squared